I'll repeat the correct version the word
scones or scones 9:25 and we're off for
afternoon tea worth it the show where we
tried three different foods at
drastically different price points to
determine which is the most fields a
little bit like Middle Earth there's
even a bedding stop I'm Anna Bennett
Pricer alongside my mum
Lucy's Tea Room been a tea room almost
30 years home baked scones and cakes all
of the session on English fat you know
anything about like the history of
afternoon tea wealthier English families
they would fit in tea and cake
mid-afternoon when they had a bit of a
lull so they just squeezed in an extra
meal just bring cranberry oh yeah
I can crest sandwiches served on fresh
bread gone to the jam and cream notice
she said scones
I think the Queen's English is gone I'm
not related to the Queen homemade cakes
on the top and a paucity of your choice
so today you're going to be eating the
today's special afternoon tea the two
people it's 2150 this is actually real
life old school England isn't it cottage
life I hate to use this word but it's
very quaint you know what everyone wants
a bit of glitz and glam but sometimes
you just want to keep it chilled I love
it
the savoury plates always my favorite
place the amount of three in there
Cheers Joey's he's on holiday yeah oh my
god simple classic sandwich to the
perfection crack an oil in the sky I
don't know what you're talking about at
all I see a scholars meaty bear boys
like perfect trying to finesse that
you've done a lot of jam yeah I've gone
overboard I'm not kidding I mean that's
the best gone about out of my life you
never go on this with homemade jam cake
time the way on that you get caffeine in
a coffee cake I do the same thing never
be wired they look like these big
exactly stodgy cakes but they're not all
that light and fluffy there's few
almonds in them the apples are so soft
it's obviously a bit of lemon drizzled
in there perfect mix well I loved every
minute of this tasted homemade nothing
pretentious it was so good the cakes
they were beautiful works of art kind of
wish I was an old lady like it's do this
every afternoon afternoon tea joke no
nothing what sorry guys it's gonna be a
sombre trip afternoon tea Thanks
okay here's a fact we're about to go
have afternoon tea
fact
[Music]
my name's grant Campbell I'm the general
manager here at dishonest and hotel who
lives in the world the hotel opened in
2000 it was seen as one of the true
first lifestyle boutique hotels in
London the afternoon tea started on the
back of through the looking glass with
Johnny Depp we actually hosted the
premiere party and celeb gossip and so
when that party was here the chef team
had decided to launch a Mad Hatter's
afternoon tea we start off with a salmon
and quail's egg Scotch egg has a small
bit of sour cream and caviar on top the
Mad Hatter's lost carrots and orange
jelly on the inside Queen of Hearts
jammie Dodger it's a strawberry jam
infused with a bit of rose one of our
most popular items - vanilla macaroon
that we have placed that white chocolate
disk on with a pocket watch on and one
of us that gets a lot of Instagram
photos taken off we've worked with our
tea supplier to create some smoke teams
have a team called the Cheshire Cat
which has a slightly orange taster the
white rabbit which is made with them
silver leaf needle tea which white
rabbits nice and lush it's gone we have
this argument all the time today you'll
be having the Mad Hatter's afternoon to
you available for 48 times per person
we're at the Mad Hatter's Tea Party
[Music]
that's what she drinks to get small
right and then you get this book which
has the menu in it I'm gonna get some
sugar from my music box
I feel really peaceful we have a blue
caterpillar shrooms
pocketwatch thing and the chess pieces
egg some foliage do you think this is
edible of course we still have some
scones all of us going love is gone
Scotch egg first well it's not your
normal scotch egg is it's got caviar on
top it's as fancy as you can get so much
flavor it's such a powerful start that
is fantastic
the Queen of Hearts okay myself look how
thick that shortbread is I'm better than
an actual down major I do think though
really cuz the jam is a lot softer
exists fresh that's what you get
what's the song so you guys I Google
could not a lot of things from the who's
thinking that a lady in Alice in
Wonderland the lady the lady with the
flat don't look at me like that
there's a fire lady and all of its was
thinking about the whole experience from
the book to the tea choices to the
ballerina it could have been crazy but
it's like a tame classier version of the
tea body yeah we've got a guy somewhere
else today eat this again I don't I
don't if I can
that was lovely
I cannot stop thinking about that Scotch
egg it's beautiful
next we're off to skip OH sketching
Mayfair everyone has seen catch on
Instagram the thing we should state
first is sketch is stunning
[Music]
hi I'm Richard war and I'm the
restaurant director at sketch Gallery
opened in 2002 name is sketch as it's a
masterpiece that I'll never be finished
that's very cool the Instagram of will
toilets or creators of the place have
actually made the worst part about
eating and dining out into the best part
our afternoon tea stand here is slightly
French inspired they're very English at
hut chef would send this special news
Bush which is a small cheese egg with
cheese soldiers mystery guests will
appear which is a small spoon of caviar
Norfolk goose egg sandwiches lended that
with some watercress hazelnut and
chocolate gateau which is everything
about French cuisine is very indulgent
very rich of strawberry tartlets to
married of watch strawberries French
strawberries so in the season and so did
I for I always have a seasonal
cheesecake available its apricot
signature Malabar marshmallow and
millibars that bubblegum brand famous in
France it's the dream really
Scotland's and the most famous particles
its cons are scales
isn't it know that there's no all so
this afternoon you be enjoying a full
afternoon tea with a glass of primary
brut champagne I see a Wes Anderson film
yeah we're in the grand Budapest hotel
yeah bit of champers oh I love alcohol
Cheers
slurp and again we have these two cheesy
breadsticks that are going in this epic
egg nice dollop of caviar rock ten
pounds worth of here
[Music]
and some caviar and champagne to kick it
off - bit unfair on the others isn't it
yeah but you know life's unfair want to
go for the one with the egg on top I'm
gonna go for the salmon the egg
mayonnaise in the middle of it mix and
having that little perfect fried egg on
top is like not even too sure what those
little eggs were popped in your mouth
and gave you another nice little punch
of the sea the way he described those
strawberries as well they're French so
they have to be good let's get on that
so thick oh I'm excited I'm really
excited I'm not a strawberries like this
they all juicy eyes it's like an upside
down cheesecake isn't it oh yeah what's
going on
so good the apricots are so sweet
everything on steroids better champagne
to top it off I'm feeling pretty good
what's a line from a Wes Anderson film I
feel like we should end it with like I
don't think I know na hey maybe we
should make this bit a bit grainy zoom
out all the places were amazing but
which is the most worth it to you
Lucy's is really good but my were that
winner is for sure the Sanderson they're
tough can't get over that Scotch egg
it's changed your life oh yeah I really
like sketch that was insane I've got to
go with Lucy okay sweet traditional and
like it was a family-run play yeah
just felt like a little content old lady
just enjoy my afternoon tea at a tea
shop wait who is quaint you pointed me
for quiet no but for a person being
described as quaint that's crap you're
interesting you're psychedelic I'm
quaint I am interesting
[Music]
[Music]